so really cool new picture has come out
to be honest it looks like a mistake so
in fact the back part was taken by the
Voyager space probe as it was wandering
past the solar system as it went past IO
one of the moons of Jupiter but the
orange stuff is the new stuff and that
was an image taken of Io of this little
bit of Io this is a tiny volcano on Io
fact this is the most active volcano in
the solar system it's called Loki this
was an image that was taken recently of
that volcano from the ground and that's
the amazing thing that things that a few
years ago we could only even hope to see
by actually going and seeing them you
know sending a space probe and actually
going up close to have a look we now
have the quality of images we can now
take with telescopes on the ground means
that you can actually see them from the
ground the scale here we're talking
about it's like a few hundred kilometers
across it's on a fairly small scale of
things and there are two clearly these
two bright patches and this kind of
looks like a horseshoe joining them up
it's full and again it hasn't been
analyzed in detail yet but it's thought
that one of them is actually the
erupting volcano itself and the other is
that this is just this massive lava lake
that forms and you can actually when you
have these larvae likes just that you
get the same kind of phenomenon on earth
they tend to crust over and then the
crust sinks and suddenly you see the
lava again and so on so what think's
happening here is that you're actually
it's one of the phases where you can see
this massive lava lake surrounding the
volcano this is in the sort of near to
medium fred so it's a few microns
wavelength so it's beyond the visible
wavelengths into the infrared part of
the spectrum which is why volcano sharp
very well because they're hot and that
so these kind of wavelengths the
infrared is a very good place to look
because you're really seeing that that
bright hot emission well it's an amazing
thing right this idea that actually
there we can take sensible pictures of
geological phenomena on a moon of
Jupiter from the ground is an amazing
that the sharpness of the image you need
to be able to pick out this kind of
detail on something so tiny so far away
is absolutely outstanding there's a
couple of limitations to how sharp an
image you can take from the ground and
in fact we've talked about these a few
times before one is that the Earth's
atmosphere messes things up and so
actually that blurs the images so you
can't take very sharp images because of
the Earth's atmosphere the other is
there's a fundamental limit that
basically
is that the the sharpness of your image
is dictated by the size of your
telescope and the bigger you make a
telescope the sharper the images you can
make and what this new image has done
it's basically sort of solved both of
those problems in the sense that it uses
some very sophisticated and it needs to
get out both get rid of the effects of
the atmosphere and to deal with this
limitation of how sharp an image you can
take with a finite size of telescope
okay so I have another picture for you
this is the telescope that did the job
it's a thing called the large binocular
telescope or the LBT it's in Arizona
it's on Mount Graham in Arizona joint
venture by several countries that run
this telescope each of these is an eight
and a half meter diameter mirror to give
you a sense of the scale of this thing
so it's a very big telescope in fact
it's two very big telescopes what's a
bit unusual about it is that they're not
independent telescopes actually both
point in the same direction so they
actually you can combine the light from
the two and either you can just use that
combined light to look at fainter things
because you've got more collecting area
so you've seen fine things but the neat
trick here is actually you can combine
the light from the two in a coherent
fashion which in terms of this sharpness
limit this diffraction limit for a
telescope means that effectively you've
got a single telescope that's kind of
the distance between the two of them
rather than the diameter of each each
one individually so the effective
diameter of the two when they're working
together I think is about 22 or 23
meters of figuring out the angular
resolution of this these images are very
very sharp images you can see very fine
detail very small angular scales it's
about 32 million seconds and I was doing
trying to figure out something that puts
that into perspective in perspective you
could see how many fingers I was holding
up from my hand if I were standing a
hundred kilometers away from you 60
miles away from you using an image of
that sharpness so it's really is picking
out incredibly fine detail because of
this very high angular resolution you
have with this 10 d if you stood I
suspect I've probably done emit brightly
enough in the infrared for it to
actually be able to record my emission
but certainly in terms of the resolution
of the images yes it will be able to
tell that but I would have to be glowing
fairly brightly in the infrared for that
to work
so that's acting like one mirror but
it's pretty clear to me there's some
pretty coals in that mirror there's a
huge gap in between and above and like
like that's like a mirror with most of
the mirror missing to me yeah and it's
actually it's worse than that because
it's if you if you think about it it's
actually bigger in this direction that
is in this direction which means in
terms of the sharpness of the images you
get the images are a much sharper in the
horizontal direction they are in the
vertical direction and you've got all
these gaps and so on so there's a couple
of again a couple of tricks you can play
which is if you think about it as you
trace an object if you think about a
kind of an extended object so here I am
with my telescope looking this way and
it's following this extended object when
an object what happens to it is as time
goes on as the Earth rotates it'll rise
and then it'll set again and if you look
at the direction on my hand you can see
that actually the star here my hand is
pointing kind of more-or-less upwards
then it becomes horizontal then it
points downwards and so actually at
different times I can use this extra
resolution the telescope has in the
horizontal direction to tell me about
different aspects of this object because
it's its orientation is changing as it
tracks across the sky and so by
combining images that you've taken at
different times as an object tracks
across the sky you can actually use that
extra resolution in all directions to
get a sharp an image which is sharp in
all aspects rather than being squashed
one way and you know very sharp in one
direction and blurring in the other
direction you can combine all those
images together to create a single image
of the object which is as sharp as if
you had a single telescope effectively
kind of this kind of size and round
because it's actually hard to get this
to work this is a you know it's a very
sophisticated technique this is probably
the best image I've ever seen taken with
this kind of technique you do have this
problem that you can't just take a
snapshot you do have to combine these
whole series of images together and then
you've got to do all this fancy
processing the object needs to be
relatively bright so you can do these
kind of techniques on it so there are
limitations to it there are still real
advantages of having a single big
telescope but what this telescope is
really giving us is kind of a foretaste
of the sorts of things we're going to be
able to do when that next generation of
big telescopes comes along because
already it's getting images of kind of
the sharpness we would get with a single
Very Large Telescope I've seen some
pretty impressive images of
by space probes that went to IO I mean
surely that's that's where it's at I
mean that you can't beat that game yeah
you can and you can see the quality of
the image we're getting you know where
you're seeing things 100 kilometers
across when you actually got your space
fro going there you can see something
which is one kilometer across or even
maybe in a hundred meters across so
clearly you get much more if you're
actually there of course the downside is
it takes you a long time to get there it
cost you rather a lot to get there space
probes are incredibly expensive we have
ignition and liftoff of Atlantis and the
Sunnyvale flight director has just
confirmed the successful deploy of the
inertial upper stage and Galileo and
typically if it's a flyby mission you
get one shot of having a look at things
and then you've gone where as here with
this kind of technique we can actually
monitor this volcano night after night
year after year to see actually how's
that structure changing how is this most
active volcano in the entire solar
system erupting
if I gave you of being whack of money or
if Bill Gates gave you a big bag of
money insolence fuel that your choice
mark do you want to build a Space
Telescope or a huge array of these
things what would you spend the money on